welcome back to the david pakman show my
name is jesse dollamore i'm subbing for
david this week i'm kind of like uh
yukon cornelius a cartoon from your
your favorite childhood christmas
special animated by some witchcraft and
brought to life
and i hold in my hand
follow-up from yesterday
yesterday i talked about a lawsuit filed
by dominion voting systems against
newsmax
oan or one america news and patrick
byrne who apparently is the ceo of
overstock.com
they're being sued for defamation in a
wide ranging multi
multi hundreds of millions of dollars
like a 1.2 billion lawsuit
for defamation
in their pursuit
of election
propaganda the big lie that donald trump
didn't in fact lose and joe biden didn't
in fact win
even though they come with zero evidence
they play their weird propaganda movies
on oan
um
produced by my pillow ding dong
it is all
surreal
and in this lawsuit
this
213-page lawsuit
it really also
illuminates another issue related to the
right
and that is their dedication to
propaganda their dedication to the lies
they're they're propping up of figures
who are not of any repute
um as experts
and that is the case that i want to talk
about today and that is from january of
2021
oan put a guy on the air
promoting him as a as an expert
mathematician a professional
uh holding expertise in advanced
mathematics
when in fact spoiler alert i'll get to
it
he is not a mathematician he holds no
degrees
he is in fact a convicted drug dealer
and according to the lawsuit
a
an installer of swing sets
[Laughter]
who claimed made wild claims that some
algorithm
flip through the election through
complex
uh
mathematical things that go way beyond
my ability i'm going to read a little
bit from this lawsuit because it is
remarkable
starting on page 101 if you happen to
have a copy of it or you're reading
along
on january 27 2021 oan broadcast a
segment hosted by trump campaign
affiliate christina bob she's an oan
employee
in which
she interviewed a supposed quote-unquote
expert mathematician
named ed solomon who claimed he had
uncovered mathematical evidence proving
that the november 2020 election results
were quote unquote impossible
and that therefore quote computer
software must have used an algorithm to
change the votes
end quote
must have been the case
solomon claimed that the results quote
can only have been done by an algorithm
it can't be done by humans
unquote says the swing set installer
after he supposedly analyzed the results
in fulton county georgia
where dominion machines were used to
tabulate votes
he then claimed that the odds
all right
now listen to this this is
one dangerous scary that we were on the
brink of having an election overturned
this is serious
but it's also laughable
that an actual network
apparently all it takes to create a
network to spread propaganda and to gin
up fear and whip republicans into a
frenzy is to have a few million dollars
laying around and willing to spend them
on the creation of a tv network if you
want to call it that one america news
which is based
just a few miles down the road from
where i live in southern california
there in san diego
this is what he said
he then claimed that the odds of those
results occurring naturally were quote 1
over 10 to an exponent so large
there's not enough stars in the universe
comma
there aren't enough atoms in the
universe to explain the number
you know
spoken like someone with an advanced
degree in mathematics
this is what passes for expertise in the
republican party it is disgusting it is
actually scary
moving on solomon's claims were
ludicrous oan knew it again i'm reading
from a lawsuit here
and at a minimum recklessly disregarded
the truth oann knew solomon's claims
were false because dominion had
expressly notified oan of independent
evidence debunking them because former
president donald trump's own
administration had debunked them and
because oan itself had effectively
acknowledged it by secretly removing
several articles and broadcast from its
own website that made similar claims
again
this is not a reputable journalistic
outlet that is not this flies in the
face of journalistic standards
there there are standard operating
procedures with journalists relative to
to correcting the record
listen
uh any endeavor that is run by human
beings is going to be fraught with the
possibility of um
incorrect information getting something
wrong
and they have rules in place
to make sure that they correct the
record that they own the mistake
deleting an article or deleting a video
because it's going to get you in legal
hot water or because it was wrong
isn't the way to do it
you note
this article has been updated to reflect
the most accurate information a previous
uh a previous edition of this article
contained an incorrect blah blah there's
a correction amea culpa if you will that
is not the case with oan because they
are not a journalistic outlet they are a
propaganda outlet serving the the the
the wild conspiracies of donald trump
serving at the mission and the behest of
a man who wants to tear down the fabric
of democracy in america
continuing with the lawsuit
oen also knew solomon's claims were
bogus because solomon was the farthest
thing imaginable from an expert
mathematician
he was in fact a convicted felon with no
college degree nonetheless oan broadcast
and endorsed as its own solomon's
preposterous and baseless allegations
that the 2020 election was rigged
through computer algorithms solomon
claimed were implemented in voting
machines in the very counties and
jurisdictions that used dominion
machines
now
other than the fact that this this
sentence in this lawsuit is in desperate
need of a few commas
[Laughter]
this isn't looking good
for oan this isn't looking good for
newsmax and i'm going to get to it uh
it's not looking good for even solomon
here
dominion notified oan this is the crux
of it though they they were they were
notified by oan all of all these things
and they still continued to do what they
did for months they're still doing it in
fact dominion notified oan that solomon
was no expert mathematician and that he
was actually a convicted drug dealer who
never graduated college and whose
current job was setting up swing sets in
long island new york
at some point thereafter oen quietly
removed the videos and story from its
originally published location on its
website
but
the video remains available on oan's
rumble page and on another landing page
on its main website
again this is what passes for journalism
and this is what passes for truth
in conservative circles
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries i know my
audience is filled with people who love
documentaries just like i do if you
don't yet have curiosity stream you are
really missing out they have all the
biggest and newest documentaries from
the world's best filmmakers i can tell
you firsthand curiosity stream has a way
better selection of documentaries than
netflix or hulu or amazon
i'm always finding documentaries on
curiosity stream that i'm not seeing
anywhere else i can watch on all of my
devices whether it's at night at home on
the couch or on the go on my phone or
wherever i just finished watching life
at the limits super interesting about
people who live
in really extreme places on earth i know
anyone who watches my show
will love curiosity stream and the best
part is that for a limited time when you
go to curiositystream.compacman
you will get 25 office subscription
which makes it just 15 bucks a year the
link is right underneath this video